après 18 jours d'audience une
cinquantaine de témoins entendus 880
pièces déposées l'enquête publique sur
la mort de Romy Norah et Martin
Carpentier c'est conclu au palais de
justice de Québec la mère des fillettes
qui n'a pas manqué une seule minute des
audiences s'est adressée une dernière
fois au coronaire Luc Malouin d'abord
émotive elle a affirmer chaque soir
avant de me coucher j'embrasse deux
urnes parfois je libère sans leur disant
combien je regrette de ne pas avoir pu
prendre leur place puis elle s'est
montrée critique envers le système qui
selon elle a abandonné étant donné que
Martin n'avait pas de dossier criminels
de propos suicidaires claires et qu'il
n'avait pas d'antécédents de violence
ces éléments ont joué contre nous les
policiers ne semblent pas avoir accordé
toute l'importance requise par la
disparition de mes enfants ma confiance
envers le système est rendu nul son
avocat abonde dans le même sens et
relève d'importantes lacunes dans le
travail de la Sûreté du Québec lors des
événements de juillet 2020 je pense que
c'est important qu'on accroche pas juste
sur le manque des ressources ça me
semble être
l'excuse facile pour expliquer ce qui
s'est passé au-delà du manque de
ressources il y a vraiment des décisions
inappropriées qui ont été prises
avec les ressources qu'on leur a aussi
donné toutes des lacunes qui selon lui
ont contribué à créer une tempête
parfaite qui aurait pu être évité en
cette dernière journée chaque partie
avait 20 minutes pour plaider les
avocats qui représentent la SQ et le
ministère de la Sécurité publique se
sont abstenus de le faire ils déposeront
plutôt des représentations écrites quant
à l'avocat des officiers de la SQ il
maintient que les policiers ont fait
tout ce qu'il était possible de faire
dans les circonstances le coronaire
avant de lever les audiences avaient un
dernier message pour la mère des
fillettes j'espère sincèrement malgré la
difficulté de cette enquête que vous en
sortirez avec des réponses à vos
questions je ne peux que vous souhaiter
le meilleur malgré toute votre peine et
toute votre douleur et que la vie
reprenne graduellement le coronaire en
chef adjoint Luc Malouin devrait rendre
son rapport assorti de ses
recommandations quelque part cet automne
ici Marie-Pierre Mercier Radio-Canada au
palais de justice de Québec